♪ ♪
>> Tucker: THERE IS A VERY
NARROW RANGE OF THINGS YOU'RE
ALLOWED TO PAY ATTENTION TO OR
CARE ABOUT OR BE MAD ABOUT, AS
YOU KNOW.
A COUPLE WEEKS AGO, MONTHS AGO,
IT WAS CORONA.
BEFORE THAT IT WAS WHITE
SUPREMACY.
NOW IT'S UKRAINE.
BUT AS YOU ARE TOTALLY ABSORBED
IN WHATEVER THAT ONE BIG STORY
IS, WHAT OTHER THINGS ARE GOING
ON?
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS FLYING
HUGE NUMBERS OF ILLEGAL ALIENS
THAT SNUCK INTO OUR COUNTRY
MOSTLY FROM TEXAS UP TO THE
NORTHEAST, WESTCHESTER,
NEW YORK.
THEY HAVEN'T ANNOUNCED THEY ARE
DOING THIS.
BECAUSE I GUESS IN A DEMOCRACY
YOU CAN DO WHATEVER YOU WANT.
WE ONLY KNOW ABOUT IT BECAUSE A
FORMER WESTCHESTER COUNTY
EXECUTIVE NOTICED.
HE OBTAINED THE FOOTAGE YOU ARE
SEEING.
SOME BUSES ARE TRANSPORTING
ILLEGAL FOREIGN NATIONALS AS
THEY LAND BUT IT'S NOT CLEAR
WITH YOU'RE GOING.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WON'T
TELL US.
IT'S NOT OUR COUNTRY.
IT'S THEIRS.
ROB IS USING THE DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS TO RESTORE POWER TO
PEOPLE.
HE IS RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR OF
THE STATE OF NEW YORK AND WE ARE
HAPPY TO HAVE THEM JOIN US
TONIGHT.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
THIS IS CONTINUING.
IF YOU BEEN ABLE TO GET ANY
ANSWERS FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
OVER WHAT THEY ARE DOING?
>> NONE WHATSOEVER.
I ASKED IN AUGUST WHEN I BLEW
THE LID ON THIS, HAD A PRESS
CONFERENCE.
WANTED TO KNOW WHO WAS COMING
IN.
WHERE THEY VACCINATED?
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES, PUBLIC
SAFETY ISSUES, THE PUBLIC'S
RIGHT TO KNOW.
DEAD SILENCE OTHER THAN CALLING
IT EVERYBODY YOU QUESTION THEM A
RACIST AND A HATER.
THEN THEN YOUR POSTED A GREAT
JOB BLOWING IT UP ON THE FLIGHTS
STOP FOR A WHILE.
STILL NO ANSWERS.
NOW THE FLIGHTS HAVE RESUMED.
ONE CAME IN SUNDAY NIGHT.
YOU HAVE THE VIDEO OF THEM.
ONE JUST CAME IN AN HOUR AGO.
WESTCHESTER COUNTY AIRPORT.
THEY ARE DEPLANING RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS GOING TO CONTINUE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION MUST
HAVE SUCH CONTEMPT FOR AMERICANS
THAT THEY ARE IMPORTING PEOPLE
FROM OTHER COUNTRIES, FLYING
THEM INTO THE INTERIOR AND
DISPERSING THEM AND THEN TURNING
THEM INTO VOTERS LIKE IN
NEW YORK CITY WHERE THERE BE
ALLOWED TO VOTE WITH A 30 DAY
RESIDENCY.
GIVE GOVERNOR KATHY HOCHUL SET
UP A $2 BILLION FUND IN NEW YORO
THAT'S A MAGNET FOR FREE STUFF
FOR ANYONE TO COME HERE.
THEY GET A PHONE.
THEN THEY GET THE EXPRESS TO
WESTCHESTER AND EVERYWHERE ELSE
AND THEN THEY GET ALMOST ALL OF
THE GOODIES IN THE ENTIRE TIME
WE THE CITIZENS WON'T GET AN
ANSWER FROM OUR GOVERNMENT.
WE GET STUCK WITH THE TAB.
>> Tucker: YOU'RE ON ELECTED
GOVERNOR.
KATHY HOCHUL HAS NEVER BEEN
ELECTED THE GOVERNOR OF
NEW YORK.
DO CITIZENS OF NEW YORK WHO PAY
SOME OF THE HIGHEST TAX RATES IN
THE COUNTRY, THEY GET FREE
PHONES AND FREE FLIGHTS, FREE
TRANSPORTATION.
>> WE GET TO WEAR MASKS ON OUR
FLIGHTS, WE HAVE TO MASK OUR
TODDLERS.
WE GET FINGERS POINTED AT US FOR
BEING BAD PEOPLE AND NOT SAYING
IT'S A GOOD THING THAT PEOPLE
ARE COMING ACROSS OUR BORDER.
WHAT'S GOING HAPPEN BY THE WAY,
TITLE 42 WHICH IS GOING TO BE
RESCINDED, THAT'S THE LAST TOOL
IN THE TOOLBOX FOR CUSTOMS AND
BORDER PATROL AGENTS SEND PEOPLE
BACK.
ONCE THEY NO LONGER HAVE THAT,
BY THE ADMINISTRATION'S
ADMISSION, THEY ARE GOING TO BE
FLOODED EVEN MORE SO YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE MORE FLIGHTS AND
MORE BUSLOADS COMING INTO OUR
SCHOOLS, OUR COMMUNITIES, AND
THEY'LL NEVER TELL US WHO IT IS.
>> Tucker: IT'S A